gears here to talk about weather with
our chief meteorologist ted florento and
ted this morning it was cloudy it was
muggy cooler but you told us about that
yeah and we had some showers this
morning too but we knew it was going to
clear out which is why that flash flood
watch was canceled christian outside
right now much quieter than yesterday
remember at this time yesterday i was
putting out all over social media about
the storms to the south now those storms
have been way off to the east lately and
that seems to be where they're going to
be staying for this afternoon and this
evening air quality actually good right
now for smoke and dust ozone still
moderate readings this could change
though unfortunately as we head more
into your weekend and we'll show you why
in just a bit let's get to some numbers
shall we sky canyon centennial hills
both at 91 degrees 86 for spring valley
north las vegas 91 now keep in mind
remember the humidity is at 36 percent
so yeah these numbers look good but
sticky outside 88 indian springs double
eights for also boulder city 91 laughlin
and still at 108 in death valley so
that's where we still retain the heat so
we saw those showers this morning notice
as this goes through circulates through
look at that drier air
drier conditions now no echoes at all on
the radar for the las vegas valley to
find those you got to go way off into
arizona and the reason for that look at
those storms there getting out of mohave
county even that's when that flash flood
watch was canceled that low pressure
that was right over baja is now
continuing to push its way eastward and
as it does it's bringing the storms
along with it we have some storms
circulating beneath this low however
that's still moving its way off towards
the east so your futurecast really
doesn't show any prospects for any
storms here tonight at least locally all
that stays off towards the east we will
see winds pick up again for tomorrow so
it could be a little breezy for some
neighborhoods tomorrow with those gusts
possibly up to 25 maybe 30 in some spots
for tomorrow but we'll see drier air in
the forecast tomorrow and beyond at
least until we get to your weekend 76
overnight skies will be clear we're
seeing that outside right now still
muggy though unfortunately for tonight
and overnight 98 for tomorrow sunny and
breezy now 99 is our normal for this
time in september
and we'll be right near that there are
your winds between 10 to 20 or sustained
winds and we'll see those gusts up to
25. highs for tomorrow 96 and tenney
hills along with mountains edge north
las vegas you'll be 97 right the century
mark for green valley and out and nellis
and also sunrise mountain 95 for
tomorrow boulder city you'll be at 96.
here's your eight day forecast dry
conditions sunny skies as we head into
the weekend we'll see some changes
though by sunday in the form of
mountains chances for storms we'll have
that slight chance on monday look at
that for a storm to return and then
after that next week partly cloudy and
hot that's your most accurate forecast
christian all your horse all right thank